are you fed up with using the bathroom
several times a night let's talk about
nocturia urinating at night when you
should be sleeping it can drive people
crazy it can be a real pain in the butt
because it interferes with your sleep so
I'm going to show you a very commonly
overlooked cause to noctua and you're
going to be very excited to hear what
I'm going to say about this because
finally you're going to find something
that really works as you're trying to
get Solutions you go online the first
page you're going to see Cleveland
Clinic WebMD Medline plus all these
credible Authority sites the same
information and they all say it's a
normal part of aging which really is
absolutely not true and they all
recommend medications but some of them
have Alternatives right they have
Alternatives they'll say well you know
you might want to try an herb but
there's no evidence and they could be
dangerous and herbs are not regulated by
by the FDA the safety of drugs are
regulated by the FDA well I guess after
the FDA finds that it's safe pretty much
stays on the market right I mean we
don't have recalls we don't have drugs
that end up being very harmful I am
being very sarcastic there is an
analysis in
2011 on adverse drug reactions okay in
the us alone 2.1 million serious
injuries 128,000
deaths from drugs but drugs are
regulated by the FDA I mean how many
people do you know that died from an
herb or had a lot of serious reactions
from herbs is it very common that being
said the information on nectaria they
usually say it's bladder infection could
be a kidney infection could be a
prostate enlargement but what's
fascinating is there's one thing that is
not listed on any of these sites okay so
just Envision what the kidneys are the
kidneys are a filter and they filter
blood and what controls this filtration
rate as well as the production of urine
okay is the concentration of various
things salts sugars waste products red
blood cell breakdown and so you have all
these different concentrated particles
in there and some of it's recycled some
of it does not get recycled when the
urine's produced it goes down these
little tubes into the bladder and what's
interesting about people have that get
up like several times a night um they're
not urinating a full bladder of urine
right it could be just a little bit so
what is up with that there must be
something going on with the sensors in
the bladder itself and maybe the valve
of the bladder so in the bladder we have
a combination of smooth muscle and
valves and nerves that are controlled by
a part of the nervous system called the
parasympathetic nervous system so that's
like the opposite or partner to the
sympathetic nervous system which is the
flight or fight mechanism this is why
you need to relax when you urinate right
if you're stressed in some way um you
know it'd be harder to eliminate so I'm
just kind of giving you a little
background here for what I'm going to
talk about so the bladder is controlled
by the uh parasympathetic nervous system
which another name for that is called
rest and digest there's another thing um
related to sugar when there's too much
sugar in the blood okay that's gets
filtered there's something that occurs
that's called and this is might be a new
term for you osmotic diuresis now what
does that mean osmotic has to do with
that uh the particles or concentration
of sugar diuresis means increased amount
of urine that is coming out so
apparently in the little filtration rate
in the kidneys if there's too much sugar
that filter will push out the sugar and
wherever there's sugar there's water
water follows sugar so we get this
excessive amount of uh water and sugar
with this osmotic diuresis thing and so
that really kind of um explains why a
diabetic for example has this excessive
urination in fact diabetics um have like
a 49% increase of noia someone with
hypertension has a 39% increase risk of
having that and someone who is Beast has
like a 200% increase risk of having
noctua and obstructive sleep apnea is at
risk like I think it's
40% of having this excessive urine
situation at night now what's
interesting about the sleep apnea
situation is I found this one paper that
did this research on the relationship
between sleep apnea and kidney
physiology that includes the bladder and
to my knowledge this is like the only
study that was ever done on this but
they found that when you have
obstructive breathing you create hypoxia
in the body that's a lack of oxygen
blood pressure does go up but your
parasympathetic nervous system goes down
remember that thing that controls not
just the smooth muscle around your
bladder but the nerves down there and
the valves well it just so happens that
they found an increase association
between hypoxia and diuresis because
apparently this lack of oxygen can
affect your bladder which is fascinating
so that's an interesting connection but
now the question is what is behind sleep
apnea what's behind obesity what's
behind diabetes and hypertension and the
answer is insulin resistance and there's
some interesting research I'm going to
put all list down below showing that
insulin resistance can cause noctua now
I did two other videos on this topic
which I'm going to put a link down below
and the comments from people who tried
it and it worked are overwhelming I mean
you're going to be blown away of how
many people just made some slight
changes in their diet and got rid of
this problem within days so how do we
fix insulin resistance stop snacking at
night
and basically stop snacking in general
in fact do intermittent fasting
basically you're just cutting down the
number of meals not the calories just
the the frequency of eating it's going
to greatly help insulin resistance and
number two uh start cutting down your
carbs to less than 30 gram per day those
two actions are the most powerful thing
you can do and you're going to see
amazing changes now a couple other
things you can do to add to speed things
up take some apple cider vinegar with
some water right before your meals just
like a tablespoon of appet vinegar what
does that do that is a really good blood
sugar regulating natural remedy okay the
other thing you could do is exercise on
a regular basis that is another potent
way to improve insulin resistance and if
you have any questions on what to eat I
have so much data on this topic on my
website um you can just download exactly
what to eat I'll put drberg.com down
below you can just click that but if you
want some hope that you can be helped
okay check out this video right here and
read all the comments of people who
started to fix their insulin
resistance